las aguas termales de ebiz por lo
general un paraíso para los turistas
vacías en tiempos de pandemia una
situación que deprime a los locales
quienes son sobre todo echan de menos a
su cliente de la russa
todos los hoteles todo está vacío los
restaurantes no pueden abrir es muy
difícil los rusos le daban vida a esta
ciudad y dinero si los rusos compraron
casi todo en x
un hotel pero también restaurantes y
comercios cuyos propietarios son rusos
como jelena en su pequeño almacén de
productos eslavos espera que la vacuna
rusa permita reactivar los negocios de
las personas que conozco que recibieron
la doctrina sputnik están muy bien no
tuvieron efectos secundarios
para el alcalde de la ciudad el turismo
termal es una prioridad y los clientes
rusos son los mejores
los clientes occidentales se quedan
cinco o seis noches
pero los casos siguen entre 10 y 12
casos son muy buenos clientes de negro
de acero miembros del partido en el
poder
el alcalde respalda la compra de las
vacunas rusa y china con o sin el
acuerdo de la comisión europea ue
a la cabeza del pulso con bruselas el
primer ministro húngaro viktor orbán no
esconde su amistad con el presidente
ruso vladimir putin a quien recibe con
frecuencia en budapest
mayor sangría es un miembro de la unión
europea y de la otan pero no por eso
debemos dejar de cooperar con rusia
ese es nuestro objetivo y seguiremos
haciéndolo
weiser hemitórax un postizo yo he venido
durante esta conferencia de prensa
virtual ante nuestra pregunta para saber
si sí o no a la vacuna sputnik era el
símbolo de una amistad especial ruso
húngara esa fue la respuesta del
gobierno húngaro hungría no tiene una
relación especial con rusia ni con
ningún otro país
hungría simplemente hace lo que puede
para proteger a sus ciudadanos de la
mejor manera posible pero según esta
analista la relación entre los dos
países si es especial y no solo en un
plano económico rastra gestiona sin
interrupción tiene muchos intereses en
el sector de la electricidad húngara
la empresa estatal rusa rosátom
construyó una central nuclear en un
planteen hungry lo cual quiere decir que
rusia tendrá una influencia enorme en
budapest uno de los símbolos de esta
cooperación es el banco internacional de
inversiones un banco de desarrollo que
se remonta a la guerra fría en el cual
rusia tiene una participación
mayoritaria en 2019 a pesar de la
controversia se trasladó de moscú a
budapest
ahí es el banco internacional de
inversiones el problema es que no
sabemos lo que ocurre detrás de los
muros de esa institución ni siquiera los
servicios de seguridad lo saben los
empleados y los clientes de ese banco
tienen inmunidad diplomática
según eeuu ese banco sería un nido de
espías rusos
su dirección lo desmiente pero otras
capitales de países accionistas se han
negado a recibirlo
claramente su presencia aquí tiene una
motivación política apareció después de
una especie de acuerdo entre putin y
orbán cuál es el beneficio para los
ciudadanos húngaros eso no lo sabemos
esta noche
bernadette y otros opositores salieron a
apoyar la última radio de oposición en
hungría privada de su permiso debe dejar
de emitir según la diputada los ataques
del gobierno contra los medios y las ong
no son novedad de segmento y todas estas
cosas ya ocurrieron en la rusia de putin
es el modelo de urbano para el putin es
algo así como una especie de mentor
ferviente opositor a la alianza de urban
computing a bernadette se le le resulta
difícil hacerse escuchar
el paisaje mediático húngaro está
dominado por el partido en el poder
controlar a denver coidh y esta media
creas tu trabajo si las personas sólo
perciben a los políticos a través de los
medios que están controlados por el
partido que de paso también controla la
opinión de los votantes
tu hogar o al igual que en rusia los
opositores al régimen húngaro han
investigado en los amigos adinerados
dirigentes encontramos oficiales a bordo
damas bodoky dirige una página de
investigación que rastrea los bienes
secretos de los oligarcas
es creer orbán formó un círculo de
personas con mucho dinero que les son
muy leales
desde entrega todos los contratos
públicos a cambio espera tener su apoyo
político
tras la publicación de estos vídeos
hungría votó una ley que prohibía gravar
con drones sin el consentimiento de los
propietarios pero eso no desanimó a
estos periodistas que prometen continuar
con su labor a pesar de todo